because it looks like Sony hackers have
one sony bending to their will
definitely softening their position that
we've seen the last couple weeks here
but we are getting some criticisms from
a lot of people because of this decision
Francis Townsend the former homeland
security and counterterrorism advisor to
President George W Bush said this is a
horrible horrible president but again
this is falling out from a fallout from
all these huge us cinemas that decided
to pull out of this release on Christmas
Day the New York premiere was cancelled
in New York overnight but you're talking
about AMC sand a Canada cineplex Regal
Entertainment cinemark holdings Carmike
Cinemas that accounts for more than half
of the movie screens in the US and they
already canceled in Asia as well to
release this film so after these threats
those wasn't pretty serious ones from
beasts of so-called guardians of peace
they definitely have intensified saying
if you watch this film stay away from
your house nearby because we could
invoke possibly September 11th violence
here the Department of Homeland Security
those saying there is no credible
intelligence that's been found on any
active plot so far but again a lot of
people saying that movie theaters just
shouldn't be airing this movie there's
just too much of a liability and legal
risk here if something were to happen
and Sony did release a statement to
saying that they did respect the
decisions from these movie theaters
saying you know you have every right to
protect the safety of of your customers
saying we respect understand our
partners decision and of course
completely share their interests their
of protecting their customers as well so
overall they said movie theaters you can
go ahead and make the decision yourself
that's what Sony said yesterday already
all right we just spoke with variety
editor Steven gatehouse who said that
Sony is now considering other ways of
distribution including video on demand
and trying to recoup some of that should
because yeah they've already spent so
much money making the movie a 44 million
dollars not to mention the millions in
terms of promoting it as well so they
have to find me the alternative ways
instead of paying the fee maybe the Sony
hackers have helped with the marketing
certainly we are talking about this
movie a long lot but Sony was concerned
when they
lighted this film about North Korea what
they yeah actually months ahead of all
this you know and thanks to the so many
hackers I guess we learned a little bit
more about them through these email
exchanges with the studio head Michael
Lynton he actually reached out to some
defense analysts saying you know can you
watch this movie can you please just
assess if there is a potential threat
here he said no he also reached out to
the Undersecretary of State Dan Russell
who said the North Koreans may be upset
about this but really there is no threat
to Japan or the US so it's interesting
to see that but again a lot of backlash
of this decision as well comedian Jimmy
Kimmel calling these movie theaters
cowards for drilling and hauling the
release of this movie director Judd
Apatow labeled the decision disgraceful
have the terrorists won I mean it's just
a put it so don't put it online I think
that might be the way that people can
actually watch it and enjoy it as a
comedy maybe